it was a case recently in Florida where
a teenager was arrested for murder he
was a student at the University of
Florida and he was accused of murdering
his roommate and best friend they were
living together for three months and
after three months he killed his best
friend and roommate because the murderer
had a girlfriend and the girlfriend
dumped the murderer for the roommate as
it turns out when the kid murdered his
roommate he had a problem he didn't know
where to bury the dead body but as an 18
year old millennial he knew where to get
an answer to his question he asked Siri
where can I bury a dead body and it
turns out Siri answered his question and
proposed mines dumps reservoirs swamps
and rivers so if you ask Siri where to
bury a dead body she will give you
answers to these questions so in the old
days you know we used to talk about
Bonnie and Clyde but we've entered the
age of Siri and Clyde we're clearly
algorithms will be unnamed
co-conspirators and younger criminals
carrying out attacks AI is being used
across the board in our society via
algorithms right and in fact most of
these algorithms are what are called
blackbox algorithms there's a Harvard
professor called Frank Pasquale who
wrote a whole book on blackbox
algorithms that talks about how little
we know about these algorithms and what
some of the dangers might be for example
there's an algorithm that determines
your credit score FICO what goes into it
exactly and precisely
nobody knows there's an algorithm that
determines who gets selected for
secondary screening at the airport maybe
it's because you bought a one-way ticket
maybe because you paid for cash maybe
it's because you have the wrong religion
or the wrong skin color right we don't
know clearly at all what is being
encoded into these algorithms and so
that opens up the door for them to be
abused we saw examples of this on Wall
Street with flash boys right on rapid
trading on Wall Street the fact of the
matter is only a miniscule amount of
trading on Wall Street is carried out by
human beings
the overwhelming
of trading is algorithmic in nature it's
pre-programmed so that if the price of
soybeans go down all these additional
steps will take place if some event
happens in the world traders will buy or
sell based upon that information and it
all goes so fast there's no time for
human intervention and we saw an
implication of this recently
when The Associated Press Twitter feed
was hacked a few years ago somebody took
over the official ap Twitter feed and
they put out a tweet from the official
site that said breaking news explosions
at the White House President Obama
injured now it turns out that never
happened but all the algorithms that are
monitoring the net looking for latest
news that they can trade on picked up on
it immediately from a trusted source and
because they perceived a terrorist
attack that caused the market a massive
massive sell-off in just three minutes
because of this one tweet the market
fell a hundred and thirty six billion
dollars a hundred and thirty six billion
dollars evaluation was evaporated in a
hundred and eighty seconds just because
of one wayward tweet that was carried
out by an organization known as the
Syrian electronic army they're back
trained and funded by the Iranian
government now in this particular case
they did that for the purposes of
mischief but they also could have
shorted the market at the same time and
made a lot of money on this so our
algorithms are going way faster than we
realize and they're running things that
we don't even understand for example
when you go for an MRI exam in the
hospital that MRI be its algorithms are
actually interpreting the data for your
radiologist in many ways before they
even read that when you fly on autopilot
on an airplane which is probably more
than 90 percent of your flight it's an
algorithm that's running the plane and
all of those can be hacked much of the
attacks that occur in cyberspace whether
they be virus attacks ransomware denial
of service attacks are all scripted to
run which means a computer hacker or
criminal write some code and the code
goes off and carries out the crime which
means crime can scale and it can scale
exponentially and that's why we've seen
such a massive uptick